monsieur prentice merci beaucoup de nous
accorder cette entrevue merci
de noter le boulot mais c'est ainsi
dites moi comment une province aussi
riche aussi béni des dieux on peut dire
que l'alberta semble aussi peu préparée
à faire face aux fluctuations du marché
du pétrole et
900 ml sexe chaque gouvernement
albertain depuis 1986 a utilisé une
portion de plus en plus grande des
revenus du pétrole pour subventionner
les services de la génération présente
au point où cette année c'est presque
100 % des revenus pétroliers qui servent
à payer les services publics courant on
ne met plus un sou quand le fonds prévus
pour les prochaines générations
on a été trop content trop chanceux trop
prospère de ce qu'on a perdu de vue les
besoins à long terme
alors je dis aux albertains qu'on doit
remettre de l'ordre dans nos finances
tout le monde souhaite qu'on maintienne
la bonne qualité de nos services publics
mais je crois que les gens réalisent
aussi qu'il faut penser à long terme
qu'on doit être plus équilibrée
diversifiée davantage l'économie être
plus intelligents
mais quand on regarde ça d'un point de
vue de l'est du pays on est assez
envieux de ce qui se passe ici il n'y a
pas de taxe de vente il ya un impôt
qu'est très bon impôt sur le revenu qui
est très bas alors est ce que ce serait
pas normal d'aller chercher plus
d'argent de ce côté là
vous avez raison les gens voient
l'alberta comme la province qui n'a pas
de taxe de vente et les gens sont fiers
ici mais les albertains sont prêts à
d'autres possibilités
ils savent qu'ils doivent faire leur
part ils comprennent qu'on a un problème
réglé
la taxe de vente n'est pas leur option
favorite
sur 26 vous savez que les sables
bitumineux un énorme problème d'image
sur la scène internationale le
gouvernement fédéral avait promis de
réglementer les industries pétrolières
il ne l'a toujours pas fait vous avez
été ministre de l'environnement au
niveau fédéral est-ce que quelle est
votre part de responsabilité là dedans
j'ai certainement la responsabilité de
régler le problème en tout cas et j'en
suis conscient vous savez peut-être que
j'adore le plein air que je suis en
faveur de la protection de
l'environnement oui l'alberta et dans le
commerce de l'énergie mais par
définition nous sommes aussi dans celui
de l'environnement nous devons être bons
dans les deux mêmes excédés mais comment
est ce que vous pouvez dire ça
il ya beaucoup d'incompréhension lancé
nous n'avons pas les avantages naturels
du québec avec son hydroélectricité par
exemple nous voulons bien développer nos
capacités hydroélectriques la nation
mais elles sont minuscules en
comparaison
nous en sommes fiers notre performance
en matière d'environnement est très
respectable on a fait beaucoup de
progrès techniques dans l'extraction des
sables bitumineux vous savez c'est un
grand succès pour tout le canada mais il
faut aussi faire savoir
mais l'opposition grandi
s'organisent de plus en plus est ce que
vous devriez pas envisager d'autres
solutions comme par exemple de vous
joindre un marché du carbone
les idées que vous évoquez on y
travaille lorsque je suis devenu premier
ministre j'ai dit qu'une de mes
principales tâches et est de redéfinir
la position de l'alberta sur la question
des changements climatiques et j'y
travaille
président barack obama a dit qu'il
s'opposerait au projet de kiss ton
excellent de pipeline il reste encore
deux ans à faire comme président des
états unis qu'est ce que vous attendez
maintenant c'est quoi l'espoir qui se
termine son mandat
on me dit que 70% des américains sont
favorables au pipeline keystone gens-là
président il l'a bien dit mais je crois
que la prochaine étape présumant qu'il
va opposer son veto et je crois qu'il va
le faire la prochaine étape je crois
c'est que le sénat va lui présenter un
nouveau projet d'investissement dans les
infrastructures américaines et ce projet
comprendra le pipeline keystone c'est
comme ça la politique américaine on
verra bien ce qui se produit ensuite ce
n'est pas ma responsabilité dont vous y
croyez encore vous êtes optimiste
le débat sur le pipeline qui se tourne
dans le fond il porte sur le choix de
transporter notre pétrole par pipeline
ou par chemin de fer est le choix le
plus intelligent on le sait mieux que
personne au canada ces partis pin un
choix plus sécuritaire et plus
responsable pour l'environnement
j'espère qu'à la fin les américains vont
faire ce jeu
mais c'est francis merci beaucoup
d'accord c'est un plaisir